لم تشهد السوشل ميديا في السعوديه الخليج
ومصر ضجه مشابهه لتلك اللي حبيبي فيها
الجزء الاول من مسلسل صالون الزهره مع
انطلاقه الجزء الثاني من العمل للفنانه
نادين نجيم يشاركها البطوله معتصم النهار
لان العمل لم ينتهي عرضه بعد المفترض ان
يصل مجموعه حلقات هذا الجزء ال 10 ولذلك
قد التقلب الحلقات المقبله الامر لصالح
العمل
حبيت اللون الاحمر يلي عملته الاسمر حلو
وهي كمان حلوه
[موسيقى]
يعني انه انت بتعجبك كثير
المميز للفنانه الكبيره سام
يه الجزائري
[موسيقى]
عبد الله
شوفي شوفي مثل لفه الماكنه الله وكيلك
الصغيره
نجاح الجزء الاول ومن يعتقد ان الكوميديا
مفتعله والحوارات تبدا تاخذ حقها من
الكتابه
[موسيقى]
قد يكون هناك بعض الملاحظات على نص على
شيء بس احنا لازم ناخذ اعتبار كوميدي يعني
هذا كوميديا خفيفه وبسيطه مش مطلوب منه
يكون مثل المسلسل التاريخي او مسلسل
الدراما اللي بيحكيلي قصه وفيها احداث
كبيره لازم ناخذ الاعتبار انه هذا ترفيه
بسيط الحلو فيه نادين نجيم الديكورات
اضاءه معتصم النهار ممثلين الهضمي خفه
الدم الصوره المبهره حسب معلومات انه في
تحضير
اهتمام العام في اقل قليلا بسبب الاهتمام
بكاس العالم
[موسيقى]